Now let's figure out how
much the single person
making $50,000 a year would
pay in state income taxes,
assuming that they're in a
state that has income taxes.
And this right here are the
current tax brackets for my state
and every state will have
different income tax brackets and
they're likely to change year
after year, but the important
thing to take away is just
how all of this is calculated.
So at the state level, you
still get ... you still,
or at least at the state I'm in,
there is a standard deduction.
It's $3,769 for a single
filer, for a single person.
And instead of having a personal exemption
which reduces your taxable income,
which is we saw at the federal level.
They have a tax credit,
a personal tax credit
which essentially just
a credit on your taxes.
So this doesn't reduce
your taxable income.
This can actually be used against
the actual taxes that you owe.
So first, let's think about what our
taxable income is in my state.
So I'm starting with $50,000.
$50,000 is my gross income
and then I have a standard
deduction in my state.
A standard deduction in my
state of 3,769 ... $3,769
gets me to taxable income in
my state of $46,231 or $46,231.
Now if you look at these brackets,
it looks like we are falling into
this 8% bracket right over here,
but just as we've said in this
... in the federal example,
that does not mean we pay 8%
on all 46,000 ... $46,231.
It means we only pay
the 8% on the increment
above $37,005. For the rest
of the brackets, we pay
1% on the first 7,000 or for
$7,124, 2% on the increment
up to 16,980. So on and so forth.
So let's calculate what that is.
So we're going to pay ...
We're going to pay 1% ... 1%
on the first $7,124. Then to
that, we're going to pay 2%.
We're going to pay 2% on
the increment up to $16,980
and that increment is
$16,980 - $7,124 and then
we are going to pay 4%
... We're going to pay 4%
on the increment up to
$26,657 and so that's
that number minus 16,890
and then we're going to pay
6% ... We're going to pay 6%
on the increment up to $37,005.
So it's 37,005 - 26,657
and then, we're in the home stretch here,
we're going to pay ...
We're going to pay 8% on the
increment ... on the
increment above $37,005.
So our taxable income,
we already saw is 46,231.
So it's 46,231 - 37,005.
37,005 bring us to ... Did
I type all that in right?
Let's see, 7 x 1% and then we have 2% x,
yep that looks right and then we have 4%.
I want to make sure I'm
typing all this in correctly.
And then 37,000 - 26,657
and then that's 6% and then
8% on that last increment.
Drum roll, please.
We get to $2,018 just based on
the brackets right over here.
So 2,000 ... So at the ... at the
state level ... At the state level,
it looks like we have $2,018
just based on our taxable
income, but now we have to
factor in this tax credit
and a tax credit as opposed
to a deduction, remember,
a deduction or an exemption
takes ... It reduces your taxable
income. A credit goes
directly against your taxes.
So we were going to pay
$2,018, but we get a credit
of $102, which gets us to what?
That gets us to 1,916 ...
$1,916 in state taxes.
So our total taxes, $9,754
at the federal level.
$1,916 at the state level and
so our actual take home pay
is going to be ... Let's
see, $50,000 is what we're
starting with. We're going
to pay ... We're going to pay
at the federal level.
I actually already figured
out in the last video
what we're left with, but at
the federal level we're going to
start off ... We're going to pay $9,754.
Then at the state level, we're
going to pay $1,916 getting us
to $38,330 take home pay.
$38,330 ... 330, is what I'm
actually ... I'm actually
going to be able to spend.
And so based on this, we can
figure out what an effective
tax rate is, based on both the
federal and state income tax.
So we are ... If we look at that
as a fraction of our original
income, $50,000, we are left
with 76.6% or another way of
thinking about it is, roughly
23.4 or 23⅓ % of your income
gets taken for taxes. That
is your effective tax rate.
So effective tax rate
... Let me write this.
Effective ... Effective tax rate
and then we're including both
federal ... federal +
state ... federal + state,
just look at the number again.
You're keeping 76.6, so you are
paying 23.4 ... 23., actually,
it looks like 23.34. So
approximately 23, approximately 23%.
If you want to think on a monthly basis,
at $50,000 you thought ...
So $50,000, you thought
that you would be taking
home $4,166 a month,
but now you're actually going
to be taking home $3,000 ...
38,330 / 12. You're only going
to bring home about $3,000,
a little bit under $3,200 a month.
So you have to plan accordingly.